yo so wild 94 1.com we got a little
boozy in the building is right down
who's a badass official name changes
right is underway the mixtape is crazy
right mixtape is crazy I just saw the
trailer motion family who has been like
hold down your visuals for a long time
and got me really excited for the yeah
it's a movie man i got like goosebumps
watching the train you saw the trade
that you would be like when it's coming
soon everything isn't moving right now
the trail album I'm not like an OG OG
boozy fan but yeah I've been radio for a
long time and I've been up on like I
became a fan I got a free motional copy
of superbad when I first came out and
mind of a maniac was the record that I
was like man yeah this that [__] they're
not then the video yes just on some
other [__] but how does it feel man
you've been out for a while now I mean
are you like I mean that the album's
done and I'm sure you've been you've
probably got so many songs in the can
already yeah man I got crazy [__] man
you know how you feeling right now on
belay I'll stay busy you know I'm on the
road you know I'm not clothing lines you
are no houses popping yeah I've been
seeing it out dtl obviously everywhere
yeah yeah this is less right now eating
my plate because I even like I'm either
in and I'm just grateful four hundred
percent touchdown to cause hell um you
know we saw a lot of the footage from
previously before you got locked up in a
trailer was it always was it always in
the in the cards to document everything
going on oh yeah it was you know I knew
I was leaving before I left right so but
I was just going to do a couple years
then so it was a already knew I already
knew I was leaving so from some from day
one it was touched down to cause hell
cuz
was going away and I knew I was coming
home stronger so you made you wanted to
make sure everything was documented
right right right right i won i won i
wanted people to see my pain and I knew
when I came back I was gonna be stronger
you know cuz I always felt like I had
their music if they ever get chip away
to go missing write your first show what
when you got out was it was a Tennessee
yeah yeah how was that feeling man cuz I
feel like you were in a certain place
before you got locked up you I've ever
seen you on the BT Wars you were doing
your theme and you had zoom going he was
on I mean you know independent and all
these records but like walking out to I
feel like you go into jail at a certain
place you come out of Joan it's just
like magnified times however many men
how was that like first initial feeling
walking out to that crowd and said no it
was just like it's just what you've been
waiting for it wouldn't know butterflies
with none that [__] your life is what
you said sat down all those years for
it's your turn it was basically oh thank
you get goose bumps as you feel like now
I should get emotional ain't had no no
no goose bumps ain't had no butterflies
in my stomach I was just ready it was
like it was overdue for me you know so
it was easy money I think I'm you
resonate with a lot of people man
because I feel like you speak for for a
lot of people who don't have a voice um
how are you feeling about what's going
on in Ferguson man there's a lot of
protests going on across the country
with my ground situation what are your
thoughts on it well I was going on in
Ferguson is you know people are people
not have about what but the vertigo of
course you notice how people take
actions out some people take actions out
in different ways some be violence some
somebody different ways you know it just
lead to violence you know I won't come
in on it too far you know a lot of
people still like you what L say L tough
situation what happens
it's just life yeah hundred percent when
you found out um that they were going to
indict the officer did you have any sort
of motion about it well not really oh
not really you even our system works
ain't find out your try got back to the
hotel and I was smiling saying somebody
named phone it was burning on call no
somebody said it was listening to to my
music say after police so that's what I
found out about it but what can we can
we expect with the album and touchdown
to cause hell okay it makes Ames crazy
that I'm coming home record it's so
crazy like those such a perfect way to
kick off the tape and Alan tell me about
the album and yeah I'm it's crazy I feel
like the joint venture me come on is
crazy 2015 is no I'm like it when you go
in like two cuz you know I'm a hip-hop
head so you know marks on my favorite I
was you know nas illmatic stuff like
that do you go into that process cuz I
feel like you're you're the kind of guy
who's got so many great album cuts but
you also got so many great singles so
when you come back with that first album
or you are you looking to put together a
body of work or you you know like like
is putting together a classic some that
that is on your mind it's just really
making my muse staying staying staying
grounded to my music and that music that
touch people with the mixtape is not
just [__] he's not
night designed to make people dance
right it's designed to touch people
trying to possess with his gun you know
you just got a great response my album
is just the same way is like when you
listen to you gonna be like damn I felt
like dying it feel like you right next
to me so that's basically a you know my
al-baker on that on that on that real
[__] you know like a like a DMX out you
know the old man that's what the cars
been missing that's what the game been
missing since like nobody questioned my
flesh blood of my blood was the last
great DMX out right yeah I'm saying
that's me when I miss those albums well
you can put it in and you ain't got a
fan for so that's what we can expect
front to back yeah what about feature
wise on the album you can come up man
that so many features i was on out hey i
got wayna Keyshia Cole life Gina's rich
homie man you got out of jail when you
got out of jail who was somebody who
reached out that wanted to work with you
that kind of like I want to say surprise
you with somebody who maybe you didn't
have a prior relationship prior to the
jail stint that you were a fan of but
once you got out y'all you know you guys
are maybe build make some music together
at least had a relationship like oh
nobody nobody I'm just you know I'm just
willing to work with people who willing
to work with me yeah I mean I feel like
you've had a lot of like like jeezy
specifically like you know what I'm
saying is all the jeezy with my home's
yeah I never sent we got believe it was
hot man i'm so mad you didn't perform
that tonight my G man that's like one of
my favorite records right there yeah you
know Jesus Jesus was my back bar I mean
definitely now you you gotta understand
i'm a DJ to minute and i gotta tell you
man set it off is like one of the
all-time like if I'm DJing a club yeah
do you understand the like how how hard
that mother [__] goes off oh yeah then
they fight off it ever you meet you in
causing fights out here yeah i got a
phone internet it do you have tammy's in
your legs yo like you'll make sure you
do that song last or did he make sure
everybody is chilled out and I drunk by
the time you do it but man so the albums
coming out 2015 yeah documentary to go
along with it right is it gonna come
with the album or yeah
seven are we driving everything Howard
how close cuz because I've been a fan I
followed motion family for a long time
because a good friend of my pill they
did a video phone call trap going ham
that kind of set off his career motion
family to me is like they're my favorite
directors how important has your
relationship with them been too well
with motion founder we go way back
because you know I want to first do put
them on one hundred-percent
hundred-percent for you start saying
most offender mind of a maniac is when
it comes to my mind Boosie bed behind it
so we just got we just gotta burn you
know they didn't know when they had a
camera and I know how to work the camera
you know it's just it's just some
professional [__] with me and motion
founder like we go in and we not get out
of me and he just makes a sick video
before I let you go I want to know
what's your favorite hip-hop album of
all time bougie if you had to pick one
touchdown and cause here nada besides
your own massage your oh you can't
that's cheap you can't cheat on this one
I did like like what Busey was 15 16
years old what was his [__] rock on DMX
DMX which sees a lot of people it's
either his dacha other that's see it was
one of my I just said this on Instagram
the other day because he was in town I'm
like yo that's the top five greatest
debut a full-time right there amen I
appreciate you my G shouts am I do care
from a larger scale